>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT WAS A WEEK AGO TODAY THAT A
DERANGED TEENAGER MURDERED 19
CHILDREN AND TWO TEACHERS IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN TEXAS.
YOU KNOW THIS BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
SEVEN DAYS OF FULL SATURATION
COVERAGE AND IT'S ALL DESERVED.
GIVEN THAT, IT'S AMAZING WHAT WE
STILL DON'T KNOW ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY.
LET'S START, JUST BECAUSE OF THE
MOST OBVIOUS, WITH HOW THE
SHOOTER COULD POSSIBLY HAVE
AFFORDED THE FIREARMS HE USED.
HE WAS 18 YEARS OLD, HE WORKED
PART-TIME AT THE DRIVE-THROUGH
AT A LOCAL WENDY'S, YET POLICE
SAID HE HAD AT LEAST $4,000 OF
BRAND-NEW WEAPONS, INCLUDING TWO
AR-15 RIFLES, 1600 ROUNDS OF
.556 AMMUNITION, A BALLISTIC
VEST, AND 60 MAGAZINES.
ONE OF HIS RIVALS WAS A HIGH-END
MODEL MANUFACTURED BY A COMPANY
CALLED DANIEL DEFENSE.
ACCORDING TO A RECEIPT THAT HE
POSTED IN PRIVATE MESSAGE, THAT
GUN COST $2,000 AND HE PAID IN
FULL.
HE COULD HAVE BOUGHT EFFECTIVELY
THE VERY SAME RIFLE AT ANY ONE
STORE FOR A THIRD OF THE COST.
BUT APPARENTLY TO HIM, PRICE WAS
NO OBJECT.
THAT'S PRETTY WEIRD.
IF POLICE KNOW WHERE HE GOT THE
MONEY TO BUY ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE AR-15s ON THE
MARKET, THEY ARE NOT TELLING US.
NOR FOR THAT MATTER HAVE THEY
EXPLAINED WHY THEY LIED ABOUT
THE MOST BASIC FACTS OF THE
SHOOTING.
FOR THE FIRST 24 HOURS THEY TOLD
US THAT A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER FIRED AT THE GOVERNMENT.
HE "ENGAGED."
BUT THEY MUST'VE KNOWN AT THE
TIME THEY SAID IT THAT THAT WAS
NOT TRUE.
THEY MUST KNOW THE RESOURCE
OFFICER WAS NOT EVEN AT THE
SCHOOL WHEN HE ARRIVED.
BUT THEY TOLD US OTHERWISE.
WHY DID THEY DO THAT?
AND BY THE WAY, HOW LONG WAS HE
OUTSIDE THE SCHOOL FIRING HIS
GUN AT PEOPLE AT A NEARBY
FUNERAL HOME BEFORE HE WENT
INSIDE AND KILLED CHILDREN?
IT SEEMS LIKE A FAIRLY SIMPLE
QUESTION, CERTAINLY AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
LAST WEEK AUTHORITIES TOLD US
THAT HE WAS OUTSIDE THE SCHOOL
FOR 10-12 MINUTES.
HERE'S THE CLAIM.
>> WE GOT A CRASH AND A MAN WITH
A GUN.
AND WE HAVE RESPONDING OFFICERS.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
IF IT'S 12 MINUTES FROM 11:30
211:40, THAT'S THE INFORMATION
WE HAVE.
>> Tucker: 12 MINUTES FROM
11:30 TO 11:40.
THAT'S THE INFORMATION WE HAVE.
BUT THAT INFORMATION IS CLEARLY
WRONG BECAUSE 11:30 TO 11:40 IS
NOT 10 MINUTES.
THE TIMELINE MATTERS, SO WHAT'S
THE REAL TIMELINE?
ON FRIDAY, THE DIRECTOR OF TEXAS
DPS CAME UP WITH A BRAND-NEW
TIMELINE.
HERE IT IS.
>> 11:20TH, THE SUSPECT VEHICLE
CRASHES INTO THE DITCH AS
PREVIOUSLY DESCRIBED.
THE TEACHER RUNS TO THE ROOM,
132, TO RETRIEVE THE PHONE AND
THAT SAME TEACHER WALKS BACK TO
THE EXIT DOOR AT THE DOOR
REMAINS PROPPED OPEN.
11:33, THE SUSPECT BEGINS
SHOOTING AT ROOM 111, OR 112,
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO DETERMINE
FROM THE VIDEO ANGLE THAT WE HAD
AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
>> Tucker: SO ACTUALLY -- AND
THAT WAS THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
SAFETY IN TEXAS -- IT WAS ONLY E
SHOOTING AT PEOPLE.
OKAY.
BUT HERE'S THE KEY TAKE AWAY
FROM THAT STATEMENT.
HERE'S WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE.
THE BACKDOOR TO THE SCHOOL WAS
OPEN BECAUSE A TEACHER AT THE
SCHOOL LEFT IT OPEN AFTER GOING
OUTSIDE TO RETRIEVE A PHONE.
SO IT'S THE TEACHER'S FAULT THAT
HE WAS ABLE TO GET INSIDE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID.
ON FRIDAY.
BUT THIS TOO APPEARS TO BE
UNTRUE.
THE "HOUSTON CHRONICLE" IS
REPORTING TONIGHT THAT
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE OF THE
SCHOOL SHOWS THAT THE TEACHER
SLAMMED THE DOOR AFTER RUNNING
BACK INSIDE AND OF COURSE THAT
WOULD MAKE SENSE SINCE BY THIS
POINT HE WAS FIRING HIS RIFLE,
AND THAT SAME TEACHER WAS USING
THE PHONE IN QUESTION TO MAKE A
PANICKED CALL TO 911.
NO ONE DISPUTES THAT.
SO WHY DID THE AUTHORITIES TELL
US OTHERWISE?
AND FOR THAT MATTER, WHY DID
THEY INITIALLY DENIED THAT THE
ON SCENE POLICE COMMANDER
ORDERED COPS TO STAND DOWN AND
REMAIN OUTSIDE HIS CHILDREN WERE
BEING SHOT DEAD INSIDE THE
SCHOOL?
ON THURSDAY, A SPOKESMAN FOR
TEXAS DPS CALLED THAT ACCOUNT A
RUMOR, BUT THERE WAS A VIDEOTAPE
TO SHOW THAT IT WAS TRUE, IT
ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
SO THE NEXT DAY, FORCED BY THE
VIDEOTAPE, TEXAS DPS ADMITTED
THE RUMORS WERE TRUE.
WATCH.
>> NONE AT THAT TIME.
>> WHY?
>> THE ON SCENE COMMANDER AT THE
TIME BELIEVED THAT IT HAD
TRANSITIONED FROM AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER TO A BARRICADED SUBJECT.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> WE ARE WELL AWARE OF THAT.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, BASED UPON
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE, THERE
WEREN'T CHILDREN IN THAT CLASS
AND THAT WHERE RISK AND IT WAS
IN FACT STILL AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
IN THAT SITUATION AND NOT A
BARRICADED SUBJECT.
>> Tucker: BUT THAT'S NOT
REALLY AN EXCELLENT NATION OF
COURSE, BECAUSE NO ONE DISPUTES
THAT EVERYONE ON THE SCENE,
INCLUDING POLICE, KNEW THAT HE
HAD WEAPONS, WAS FIRING THEM AT
PEOPLE TO KILL PEOPLE AND WAS
INSIDE THE SCHOOL WITH CHILDREN.
NO ONE DISPUTES THAT.
SO WHY DID HEAVILY ARMED POLICE
UNITS DECIDE NOT TO STOP A
SAILBOAT OR EXECUTING CHILDREN?
IF NOT FINGER POINTING TO ASK
THAT QUESTION, THESE ARE COMP
LOCATED CIRCUMSTANCES AND PEOPLE
MAKE MISTAKES.
BUT WE ARE MAKING LONG-TERM POLY
DECISIONS BASED ON THE DECISIONS
THAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK IN
UVALDE.
POLITICIANS ARE CALLING FOR
MILITARIZING AMERICA'S ENTRY
SCHOOLS AND GET THEY CAN'T
ANSWER WHAT THE MILITARY FORCE
EFFECTIVELY OUTSIDE THIS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL REFUSED TO
STOP THE KILLING.
SO THIS MASSACRE COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED AT SOME POINT.
IT WAS NOT PREVENTED.
WHY WAS THAT?
WE SHOULD KNOW THE ANSWER.
BUT DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
NO ONE IN POWER SEEMS ANXIOUS TO
HOLD THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT HAPPENED IN UVALDE.
AND AMAZINGLY -- AND THIS IS SO
PERVERSE IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
IT'S TRUE, BUT IT IS -- SOME
SEEM DETERMINED TO MAKE FUTURE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS MORE LIKELY.
IN CALIFORNIA, THE STATE
ASSEMBLY JUST VOTED TO END THE
REQUIREMENT, THE LONG-STANDING
REQUIREMENT THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE AFTER SCHOOL SHOOTINGS,
THAT SCHOOLS ALERT
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN STUDENTS
"ATTACK, SALT, OR PHYSICALLY
THREATEN SCHOOL OFFICIALS."
THAT'S NO LONGER IN PLACE, AND
ACCORDING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THAT'S A WIN FOR EQUITY.
IF WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL, A
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR,
STEPHEN BRADFORD, SAID SO.
HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD
"THE DAILY CALLER."
"BLACK STUDENTS, LATINX COLORS,
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND STUDENT OF
DISABILITY'S ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REFERRED TO
LAW-ENFORCEMENT, CITED, AND
ARRESTED."
SO TOO MANY LATINX STUDENTS IN
WHEELCHAIRS ARE APPARENTLY BEING
BLAMED FOR SCHOOL SHOOTING SO
THERE IS NO MORE VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL'S AT ALL.
HOW DOES THAT HELP PREVENT THE
NEXT SCHOOL SHOOTING?
IT DOESN'T.
BUT IT STARTS TO SING WITH
HELPING PREVENT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
IS NOT REALLY THE POINT OF THIS
EXERCISE, AMASSING MORE POWER IS
THE POINT.
AND WE KNOW THIS FROM WHAT'S
HAPPENING NORTH OF US.
CANADA'S BOTOX DICTATOR
JUSTIN TRUDEAU WASTED NO TIME
USING THE TRAGEDY IN THE U.S. TO
HIS OWN POLITICAL ADVANTAGE IN
CANADA.
UVALDE IS MORE THAN 2,000 MILES
FROM OTTAWA BUT BECAUSE OF WHAT
HE WAS ALLOWED TO DO IN TEXAS,
CANADIANS ARE NO LONGER ALLOWED
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU HAS INTRODUCED A
BILL THAT WOULD BAN CANADIAN
CITIZENS FROM BUYING, SELLING,
AND TRANSFERRING HANDGUNS WITHIN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
HANDGUNS WERE NOT THE CAUSE OF
THE SHOOTING IN UVALDE.
UVALDE IS NOWHERE NEAR CANADA,
AND YET JUSTIN TRUDEAU IS USING
THAT TRAGEDY TO DISARM ANYONE
WHO DISAGREES WITH HIM.
BY THE WAY, THAT LAW WOULD
EMPOWER COURTS TO CONFISCATE
GUNS FROM PEOPLE, EVEN IF THEY
NOT COMMITTED A CRIME.
WATCH JUSTIN TRUDEAU ANNOUNCE
THIS POWER GRAB AND AS YOU DO
WATCH, PAY SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
THE MASKED TOADIES BEHIND HIM
NODDING IN UNISON.
>> WE ARE INTRODUCING
LEGISLATION TO IMPLEMENT A
NATIONAL FREEZE ON HANDGUN
OWNERSHIP.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT IT WILL
NO LONGER BE POSSIBLE TO BUY,
SELL, TRANSFER, OR IMPORT
HANDGUNS ANYWHERE IN CANADA.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE ARE CAPPING
THE MARKET FOR HANDGUNS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: WAS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING HERE IS THAT PEOPLE
ARE JUSTIN TRUDEAU KNOW THAT
THEIR RULE IS ILLEGITIMATE, THEY
KNOW PERFECTLY WELL HOW RESENTED
THEY ARE, AND THEY SPENT AN
AWFUL LOT OF TIME THINKING ABOUT
CIVIL UNREST.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T.
YOU LIVE IN A DEMOCRACY, SO YOU
DON'T IMAGINE THAT ANYONE NEEDS
TO BE DISARMED FOR POLITICAL
REASONS, BUT PEOPLE LIKE
JUSTIN TRUDEAU AND FEEL THE DEEP
RESENTMENT IN THEM AND THEY ARE
FULLY INTENT ON DISARMING THE
POPULATION.
WE REACHED OUT TO
JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S OFFICE TODAY
ABOUT THIS NEW LAW, WE WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU WILL APPLY THESE
LAWS TO HIMSELF.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE FIRST AND MOST
IMPORTANT TEST OF SINCERITY, IF
IT'S GOOD FOR ME, IT OUGHT TO BE
GOOD FOR YOU TOO AND VICE VERSA.
SO IN THIS CASE, WILL
JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S STATE-FUNDED
BODYGUARDS BEAVER BE REALLY
CRUSHING THEIR HANDGUNS, AND HOW
ABOUT THEIR BAND AR-15s?
WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO KNOW THAT
ANSWER BECAUSE WE -- "WE DO NOT
COMMENT ON MATTERS RELATED TO
THE PRIME MINISTER'S SECURITY,"
THEY RESPOND, WHICH MEANS OF
COURSE NOT.
HE'S NOT THAT STUPID, HE WILL
CONTINUE TO PROTECT, PROTECT HIS
OWN FAMILY, YOU WILL JUST NOT BE
ALLOWED TO PROTECT YOURS IN
CANADA.
AARON UNITED STATES, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE WATCHING VERY
CAREFULLY WHAT HE IS UP TO AS
THEY PLAN OUR FUTURE HERE.
ALREADY THE RHETORIC OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS CHANGED.
FOR YEARS DEMOCRATS, JOE BIDEN,
THE MEDIA, HAVE TALKED ABOUT
BANNING AR-15s, THE SO-CALLED
WEAPONS OF WAR, WHICH ARE NOT IN
FACT USED BY ANY MILITARY BUT
WEAPONS OF WAR HAS BEEN THERE
FOCUS.
WATCH.
>> President Biden: THE VENOM
OF THE HATERS AND THEIR WEAPONS
OF WAR.
>> ASSAULT STYLE WEAPONS THAT
ARE WEAPONS OF WAR.
>> AND PURCHASE THESE WEAPONS OF
WAR.
>> TO GET THESE WEAPONS OF WAR.
>> FINALLY RIDDING OUR STREETS
OF WEAPONS OF WAR.
>> WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS
TAKING THESE WEAPONS OF WAR OUT
OF THE HANDS OF CIVILIANS.
>> BECAUSE THEY SEE WITH THESE
WEAPONS OF WAR DUE ON THE
STREET.
>> AN ASSAULT WEAPON IS A WEAPON
OF WAR.
WITH NO PLACE, NO PLACE IN A
CIVIL SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: THEY WOULDN'T KNOW
WHAT ENDS THE BULLET COMES OUT
OF.
THEY KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THIS
TOPIC.
IF THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
BASIC CRIME STATS.
IN THE UNITED STATES, RIFLES
KILLED FEWER PEOPLE EVERY YEAR
THAN FOR STORE KNIVES DO.
THE SNOW EFFORT AFOOT TO BAN
KNIVES OR FISTS BUT WEAPONS OF
WAR HAVE LONG BEEN THERE FOCUS,
MEANING AR-15s, THE SINGLE
MOST POPULAR SELF-DEFENSE RIFLE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SELF-DEFENSE IS THE POINT.
ON SUNDAY, CONGRESSMAN
ADAM KINZINGER HAS DECIDED, AND
SAYS IT OUT LOUD, THAT IN ORDER
FOR HIM TO FEEL SAFE, WE ARE
GOING TO NEED TO CONFISCATE YOUR
RIFLE.
IF BECAUSE HE FEELS UNSAFE.
WATCH.
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOU DO STILL
OPPOSE A BAN ON THE KIND OF
ASSAULT WEAPONS THAT WERE USED
IN THE SHOOTING.
CAN YOU EXPAND MY PRIVATE
CITIZENS NEED WEAPONS OF WAR?
>> LOOK, I HAVE OPPOSED A BAN,
YOU KNOW, FAIRLY RECENTLY.
I THINK I'M OPEN TO A BAN NOW.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU EXPLAIN,
CONGRESSMAN, WHY PRIVATE
CITIZENS NEED WEAPONS OF WAR?
CNN ANCHORS NEED TO BE
SURROUNDED BY BODYGUARDS WITH
WEAPONS OF WAR BECAUSE THEY ARE
IMPORTANT, BUT YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY, NO.
YOU DON'T NEED WEAPONS OF WAR.
FOR YEARS IT'S BEEN ABOUT THE
AR-15, BUT THINGS ARE CHANGING.
JOE BIDEN IS NOW CALLING FOR A
BAN ON THE UBIQUITOUS
9-MILLIMETER ROUND.
WATCH THIS.
>> President Biden: A
9-MILLIMETER BULLET, THOSE
BELONG OUT OF THE BODY.
SO THE IDEA THAT THESE HIGH
CALIBER WEAPONS -- THERE IS
SIMPLY NO RATIONAL FOR IN TERMS
OF ABOUT SELF PROTECTION,
HUNTING.
AND REMEMBER, IT'S NOT THE
SECOND MOMENT, IT'S NEVER
ABSOLUTE.
YOU COULDN'T BUY A CANON WHEN
THE SECOND AMENDMENT WAS BAD.
>> Tucker: THERE'S A GUY WHO
CAN'T EVEN RECOGNIZE HIS OWN
WIFE OF 40 YEARS IN PUBLIC
LECTURING US ABOUT WITH THE
RATIONAL BASIS IS FOR THIS.
"THE RECENT WHEN A RATIONAL
BASIS FOR THE 9-MILLIMETER ROUND
IN TERMS OF SELF PROTECTION."
OF COURSE THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
IF THE 9-MILLIMETER IS THE MAIN
SELF PROTECTION ROUND IN THE
UNITED STATES, ALONG WITH THE
.556, AT THE ROUND USED IN THE
AR-15.
BOTH OF THEM ARE SMALL ROUNDS.
PEOPLE USE THEM TO PROTECT THEIR
FAMILIES, AND IF YOU TAKE THEM
AWAY, AMERICANS WILL NO LONGER
BE ABLE TO DEFEND THEMSELVES IN
THE MIDDLE OF A CRIME WAVE THAT
WAS WHOLLY MANUFACTURED BY THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
STRIP YOUR GUNS FROM ME.
AND THAT'S OF COURSE THE POINT.
THIS IS A POWER GRAB, AND YOU
CAN BE CERTAIN THAT IT IS A
POWER GRAB AND NOT AN EFFORT TO
MAKE THIS A SAFER COUNTRY
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WERE CALLING
FOR IT ARE EXEMPTING THEMSELVES
FROM ITS REQUIREMENTS ONCE
AGAIN.
THAT IS THE ACID TEST.
IF YOU ARE FOR A LAW, WILL IT
APPLY TO YOU?
TO MICHAEL LIMBURG'S BODYGUARDS
CARRIED THE DREADED
9-MILLIMETER, DO THEY HAVE
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES?
DID NANCY PELOSI'S BODY GUARDS,
BUT WHAT YOU PAY FOR, DO
MITCH McCONNELL'S BODYGUARDS
CARRY THOSE ROUNDS?
WE WANTED TO KNOW, WHY WOULDN'T
WE WANT TO KNOW, WHY DON'T WE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW?
SO WE EMAILED ALL THREE OF THEIR
OFFICES TODAY.
LIKE JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S OFFICE,
NONE OF THEM EVEN REPLIED TO --
BOTHER TO REPLY TO US.
I WAS THERE THEY WON'T BE
DISARMING THEIR OWN BODYGUARDS.
THEY WILL KEEP THEIR OWN WEAPONS
OF WAR IN THE MEANTIME THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO PASS LEGISLATION
AGAINST WEAPONS THEY KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT.
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
DECADES.
WE DID A DOCUMENTARY ON THIS,
ACTUALLY, AND WE SPOKE TO
PROBABLY THE PERSON WHO KNOWS
MORE ABOUT SELF DEFENSE WEAPONS
THAN ANY LIVING AMERICAN, ONE OF
THE MOST POPULAR FIGURES ON
YOUTUBE AND TRULY AN EXPERT ON
THE USE OF FIREARMS FOR
SELF-DEFENSE.
HERE'S PART OF WHAT HE TOLD US.
>> AND OF COURSE IT IS THE
FAMOUS TUCKER CARLSON BARREL
SHROUD ON IT.
>> HICKOX 45 IS REFERRING TO
CONGRESSMAN CAROLYN McCARTHY
OF NEW YORK, WHO FAMOUSLY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE FIREARM SHE WAS
TRYING TO BAN.
>> DO NOTA BARREL SHROUD IS?
>> I ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT A
BARREL SHROUD --
>> SENIOR LEGISLATOR.
>> SO A BARREL SHROUD MAKES
RIFLE MORE DEADLY?
>> SHROUDS THAT BARREL.
>> A LOT OF WHAT PEOPLE COME UP
WITH, THEY DO NOT KNOW FIREARMS,
THEY JUST DO NOT LIKE THEM, THEY
HATE THEM, THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
REASONS TO HATE THEM AND THEY
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
CARTRIDGES.
A BULLET IS DANGEROUS, LET'S
FACE IT.
A HAMMER, CHAINSAW, A LADDER, A
CAR.
THEY ARE POTENTIAL